Jordan Woods denies claims she shaded
her former BFF Kylie Jenner we just
really have to watch our backs but I
feel like now in this generation people
always have motives earlier this month
the 25 year old shared this Tick Tock
causing fans to think she's proud of
having naturally plump lips and many
users took it as a slight jab toward the
beauty Mogul who's known for her lip
kits
[Music]
yeah so while Jordan sang the weekend's
lyrics to party monster she didn't
explicitly mention Kylie but wrote in
the caption thank you Mom and Dad for
these genetics the comment section was
flooded with accusations calling out
Jordan for allegedly dissing Kylie but
she responded quote there's no shade
towards anyone this is a trend I've seen
a bunch of girls doing and I wanted to
hop on
together her and I we just always build
each other up no matter who it is
whoever I'm around I just want to see
them do as their best Jordan and Kylie
were besties for years we do have that
tight Circle she even appeared on the
Kardashian Jenner family's hit reality
shows here's to Jordan and Kylie foreign
but their friendship came crumbling to
an end back in 2019 when Jordan
confessed to kissing Tristan Thompson
Kylie's big sis Khloe Kardashian's baby
daddy while the couple was still
together he did kiss me and after a lot
of back and forth between Jordan and the
family Chloe revealed where she in the
model stand during part two of The
Keeping Up with the Kardashians reunion
special I don't have any grudge against
Jordan I think people make mistakes
people live and they learn I have to
forgive these people for me and it's up
to them to forgive themselves and to be
accountable and learn and hopefully
don't repeat these same Cycles Kylie
also opened up about how things ended
with Jordan when we were friends we
never thought that we wouldn't be
friends it was kind of an overnight
thing we've had these conversations if
Kylie once we've had a lot of
conversations Jordan to be her friend
that's up to Kylie
foreign